so I've been working a few years at
reactor as a software developer and
sometimes we've given this book out to
new colleagues when they join the
company called leadership and
self-deception which talks about the
ways in which we sort of put ourselves
in these boxes in which we deceive
ourselves and we think of other people
not as not as people but as sort of
obstacles and enemies and things that
are getting in our way so I rewrote the
book JavaScript and self-deception and I
thought we could talk a little bit about
the ways in which we deceive ourselves
both both when we write JavaScript and
also when we talk about JavaScript sort
of from an outside perspective and the
ways in which JavaScript is good and bad
so there's this argument that you hear
quite a bit that goes kind of like this
javascript sucks it has it has weird
equality handling all right turning this
in this example we an empty array is
true null is false or an empty array is
false that's true no less false that's
false and it's weird number handling
point one plus point two is it's almost
point three you know we're trying it's
close as weird type coercion if you had
a if you had the string two to two you
get 22 as a string if you subtract the
two you get zero as a number it has a
weird this so you call the same function
two different times
you're getting two different this within
the function depending on how you called
it depending on what's on the left side
of the dot or if there's nothing on the
left side and defaults to window unless
you're running a node yes and that's
weird scoping if you forget to use bar
or Const or lat
then things will get defined in global
scope by default and it's weird hoisting
if you define two functions in slightly
different ways then one of them will get
magically sort of hoisted to the top of
your module except it's not a module
because javascript doesn't have modules
it has two types of null right it has
null and undefined just to make things
more difficult that's not a number and
infinity it has no modules by default
septon sort of newer versions of
JavaScript it has no types everything is
mutable it has callback Cal so
javascript sucks right no so this is
this is basically a strawman argument
and this this might be the original
straw man here that's getting blown up
in this picture from Wikipedia so
there's there's an argument you could
make there but I think it's it's much
more subtle than the argument you hear
most of the time because most of those
problems they aren't really real
problems in practice you run into these
run into a lot of these things quite
rarely it's not really a problem except
when you're trying to learn JavaScript
and you're wondering what the heck is
going on and most of these have easy
sort of widely adopted solutions so
basically this is looking at JavaScript
at it's very worst and saying look
JavaScript sucks but so what if we take
sort of the opposite approach if we if
we do sort of the the steal man argument
for JavaScript JavaScript at its best
and so these these are my opinions this
is how I think you should write
JavaScript you may have your own
opinions they might also be good but
you're welcome to use these ones so I
hope to write JavaScript use a build
tool webpack browserify
whatever it is you get modules that sort
of thing use a linting tool which gets
rid of most of your issues around around
weird equality rules and things like
that
don't use double equals use the triple
equals you kind of have to know
truthiness just because you do run into
that stuff
don't use var use constant light don't
use this you don't need it you can pass
arguments to functions don't use classes
you don't need classes pass arguments to
functions unless you're using library
that uses classes then you use classes
but you don't need to write classes you
use futures or promises callback hell is
is not a thing in JavaScript dirt should
not be because everyone who's doing
asynchronous requests is using something
promises like or lazy futures like in
future use a functional library use
something like rammed I use F pts
use these kind of tools to make it easy
to do it easier to do data
transformations use validation use
something like JSON schema or something
based on that or IOT s if you're using
typescript use types
I don't consider typescript and flow to
be really different languages it's just
types on top of JavaScript use pure
functions use the ternary operator don't
do side-effects use immutable data if
nothing else use it by convention but
otherwise you can pull in libraries like
immutable J s or more--or this sort of
thing or you could sort of take the easy
route you could just use pure script if
we look at so peer script is a strongly
typed functional language that compiles
to JavaScript how do you write pure
script based on this sort of listing use
the build to a well just use the default
use bottles thing you download it you
use it it's what most people use use a
lending tool well if you like it doesn't
really have the problems that you need
to really need a lent into a foreign
JavaScript don't use double equals well
it works exactly as you would expect so
you can forget about this rule don't
need to think about it understand
truthiness it also works exactly as you
would expect forget about it don't use
var it doesn't have variables in the
same way it works how you would expect
don't use this
there's no this don't use classes no
classes use futures or promises use app
it's like lazy futures but a little bit
better use a functional library well
it's sort of functional by default it's
all built-in it's all functional use
validation well it's also kind of built
in by default things are validated at
least on the type level basically by
default in there lots of tools built up
around that use types built-in strongly
typed use peer functions they're all up
here
it's built in
use the mutable data it's immutable by
default so basically out of most of the
things I've learned in the past few
years by writing JavaScript I could have
skipped all the effort and just learned
pure script and that would have been
enough
you just write pure script and that
doesn't mean it's good code you can
still write crappy Pierre is good but
we've sort of we've raised the level
we've written you can follow these rules
to write the best JavaScript you can
write or you can sort of start at that
level and work upwards and that's
basically the argument that's the whole
that's the top great thing but if you if
you want to hear the longer story I can
talk a little bit more but so what I'm
gonna talk about now is data because we
use data all the time we take in data we
transform data we push out data that
sort of thing
fear because we're all afraid we're
afraid of our stuff breaking we're
afraid of taking down servers in
production that's her thing trust
because we want to trust the code that
we write we want to trust that what we
write actually works and will work in
the future and we can refactor it if we
need B if we need to to make it work
later for other things JavaScript
because we have to deal with JavaScript
quite a few of us are sort of have to
deal with it in some at some level and
the path beyond so if we look in
JavaScript at one example what does the
data look like in JavaScript what is
sort of the shape of the data so by
default in JavaScript you do this thing
where you kind of pretend it's what you
want so here in our example we fetch
something over the network we fetch a
user by ID we get back to user and we
say yes I've got my user this is great
and then later we need to do something
with that user or maybe we display its
name so we render its name and we're
like all right it's got a name you're
doing well and you're basically you're
trusting that the other systems that you
work with will return the data in the
cracked format and this might work fine
if you if you wrote the back end and you
kind of be like well you know I'm pretty
good I know what I'm doing I trust these
guys I work with
maybe that's fine and you're trusting
the other developers that you work with
you're testing also that they're not
going to change the user within your
codebase but then after a while that the
fear starts to creep into your codebase
and this is this is what figer looks
like in a codebase so you get your user
now there's a little bit of uncertainty
you're not quite you're not quite sure
maybe maybe it doesn't have a name
anymore
maybe the users are coming from
different places now so you check that
and you throw an error and you check
another thing you do this in sort of an
ad hoc way and then then later down the
line you're trying to render your user
and you you're not quite sure if it
still has all the things you had on it
because things changed in the meantime
but so one way you can sort of try to
alleviate this fear is to pretend really
hard so you take typescript and you say
alright now I've fetched my user by ID
and I get back a user but now it's a
capital u user if you notice up here
it's got a capital u that means it's
different right
well you're not actually you're not
actually checking the user at that point
in the default case you're just kind of
you're saying we got a user and now now
it has a type it has an ID and a name
and an email and that's what we're
expecting to get here but then then
after that point
typescript kind of helps you verify that
at least within your codebase you're
using a user as a user and you're not
doing weird things with it so it gives
you that sort of internal consistency
but it isn't it doesn't help you with
the outside world
you're still trusting other systems when
you do this and then you're still
trusting the developers when they're
your project dry crack types which can
be a problem as well you're also
trusting that within typescript none of
the types and sort of the path of things
you're doing have any type which means
basically it doesn't have a type we're
disabling type checking within this path
of our code and so you might also want
to introduce validation to be able to
handle sort of external data you get
your external data you validate to your
user then you throw an error then and
basically this idea of failing quickly
at the trust breaks down
and you might use something like JSON
schema for this but then you have to
write out these long sort of objects
with for validating your JSON and these
things get sort of laborious to write
and it's hard to maintain and in the end
it's you're kind of you're trusting
developers to not be lazy and not update
these things and this sort of thing and
it's it's going to it's going to be
difficult so another way you could do it
is do sort of validation and use
typescript right and then you get this
sort of trust of trust you're still
trusting that your types are correct
within your code base which I might
touch on a little bit later and you're
trusting other developers to write
correct types and your types to not have
any and that's her thing but you get you
get more trust in your code and if you
do this with something like typescript
JSON schema you can just write the
typescript type and then there's a
little bit of boilerplate around it in
the first time but then after that you
just write the types and it generates a
valid area for that or if you use
something like io TS you can do that in
sort of the other direction you write a
validation object and then you get the
type from that so you can you can only
write it in one place and it's easier to
maintain but so what does the same
example look like if we look at it from
the peer skroob perspective so the great
Irish playwright and poet Oscar Wilde is
also the the greatest developer of the
Victorian age unbeknownst to many and so
Oscar Wilde tweeted the other week or
sometime ago I mean that a good language
will always stab you in the front pier
script stabs you in the front so if you
look at the same example from Pier
script here we're basically doing we're
doing the same thing as before we said
this load and render a user function on
the bottom which calls to load the user
we fetched some user of the network then
we do this read JSON to parse it into a
user and if we have errors we've logged
errors or if we have a user we render
the user so it's pretty it basically
looks like what we ended up doing on the
JavaScript side
you have this sort of validation by
default it has this call to read JSON
there which checks to see that the data
you're getting is the type that we wrote
up there it's a user with an ID and
maybe an email and it has a name that
string and you have sort of within your
code base you have strong types you
don't have NOLA undefined you don't have
any weirdness the types are just
whatever the type definition says and
you don't need to think about it anymore
so you can trust you can trust that the
data within your code base has the shape
that you expected to have and it'll stay
that way and the boilerplate around that
validation bit is this you write your
type like you do anyway and then you
call read JSON usually string and in a
lot of simple cases it'll be just like
this so you sort of get you sort of get
this validation part of it for free so
another example from the JavaScript side
how does the how does the data change in
JavaScript so by default the data just
sort of changes willy-nilly he changed
things you you take in a document in
this function that you need to format
you taking some source and you just
change your document you convert the
date while you're doing it maybe you set
it - no - no and you set this source on
your document and this might be fine it
might be fine in small cases but then
but that and this is sort of a a
cherry-picked example in a way but it's
meant to be more of a representative
example than cherry-picked example
because you see this you see this a lot
and then and the problem here is that
the flow is really hard to follow
you're taking this document and to
understand what the document looks like
you have to follow it at every point
throughout this function and this gets
worse and worse as your code code gets
larger and then there's also sort of
this this fear that can come up
especially if you're doing it highly
concurrent processes now what if this
documents used elsewhere and now we've
just changed it and now we betrayed the
trust of whoever wrote the code that
does the other part which might have
been you the other week
you turn two types but these types won't
save you right so here's the same
function and then below we have a second
function that has exactly the same type
in typescript it takes in you look at
the type it says it takes in a document
and it takes in a string and then it
returns void which means it does nothing
right it's good does nothing but then if
you look at the bottom type or the
bottom function then we're launching a
rocket and we're removing your
filesystem
well we format our document but they
have the same type but so one way you
might get around this is to do this sort
of pretend immutability right you're
working with experienced people maybe
you do this thing where you know you're
not doing weird things instead of
changing data you create new data or you
copy things where you have to and so
here we take in a document in source and
instead of instead of mutating the
document we just return a new document
that has new stuff
we're not mutating data we're not
deleting the root directory we're not
launching in your rockets and this this
can work pretty well if depending on
your team you can get pretty far just by
kind of trusting that everyone follows
these sort of norms but you might want
something stronger so you could you
could turn to libraries which is like
pretending really hard so if you use
something like Ram de then it has for
doing sort of functional data
transformations by default that won't
mutate the data that you using or if you
use something like immutable J's then as
long as you're using immutable J's as
data structures you can't actually
mutate those data structures but you
have to convert back and forth between
other JavaScript structures and both of
these sort of depend on depend on other
developers using these tools it has to
be the convention has to be pervasive
within your code base for this to really
make sense and there are other tools you
could use to do this you could use
partial lenses from BES out here in the
middle or you could use sanctuary or
mori or underscore lodash for these
kinds of things but you're still sort of
shifting you still have the trust on the
developers you're trusting the team to
use these tools
so if we look at the same example again
from the pier scripts add another quote
from Oscar Wilde the bravest developer
among us is afraid of himself the
mutation of the data has it's tragic
survival in the self-denial that Mars
their lives I think he was a man ahead
of his times so the same example in pure
script looks pretty similar in the end
to our sort of functional conventions
example in JavaScript so here we we take
in a source document and a string and we
return a document and the thing we
return is just another record that we
create from there and if we have a date
we might convert convert the format on
the date and basically it looks it looks
pretty similar the thing you might have
written in in JavaScript anyway right
but there's some there's some subtle
differences there it can't actually
mutate the data if you look at the type
it takes an SRS document in a string it
returns the document it doesn't say
anything about changing things it
doesn't say anything about mutations
doesn't say anything about launching
rockets all right it just takes in
things and returns things and there's
those other changing it or launching
Rockets are not in the type but suppose
you actually do want to change it you
want to mutate this data well then it
looks like this instead of taking in a
source document we're taking this
mutable reference to a starts document
and then instead of returning just
another document we return this effect
this tff unit which says we're doing
some side effect and we're not returning
any other value and it doesn't tell you
necessarily what side effect you're
doing but just tells you that it's doing
something and you might decide later
that you're not actually going to run
this side effect you might say we're
going to build up this stream of effects
and then we'll run some of them and
we'll ignore the others it hasn't
actually run again and we still can't do
things like mutate our document just
arbitrarily it says it's immutable
reference to a source document so you
can only give it fields that are in the
source document
and we can't mutate other things that
aren't that aren't represented in the
type is something that can be mutating
so suppose you actually do want to latch
the rocket you could do that too but
then again it shows up in your type here
we're we're returning a side effect and
then when someone else who uses this
code that's to format a document you
might wonder why why this why this is
returning a side effect why why do we
need a side effect just to format this
document and if you really really want
to mutate it maybe for performance maybe
for some other reason you can cheat and
do it in JavaScript so you write this
import declaration on the top say we'll
use format document from the JavaScript
side then in the JavaScript side you
just do whatever you want and you can do
that but you probably don't want to you
sort of you lose all that trust that you
gained but if you need to it's there and
so there are a few different examples
here that I showed but some some tools
in JavaScript that you can use for
gaining trust that we talked about were
optional types validation immutability
and then using these sort of functional
transformation libraries so I'm not
going to talk about validation and
functional transformations just because
even though you do you kind of get that
by default in pure script without
thinking about it but there are tools
for doing in JavaScript it works alright
and you might need to do other
validation anyway but so but there are a
few problems with optional types and
with sort of functional programming in
general so optional types need this sort
of skill and Trust to be effective in
JavaScript and then basically functional
programming at some level when you're
doing functional programming you have to
choose between functional programming
your types or JavaScript you can pick
two of those options
so optional types need some skill or
trust to be affected basically because
they're optional by design you can not
use them and so it depends on developers
actually using these things and you
probably want to tighten up
configurations you probably want to make
types not so optional in the end if you
want to actually be able to trusted or
you just kind of use them here and there
but then you don't really get anything
from it and a lot of things are hard or
impossible to type out in flow or type
script so this has gotten this has
gotten slightly better for some things
but a lot of these things are built in
to the design of type scripted flow just
because they're trying to maintain
compatibility with JavaScript and some
things in JavaScript are just not
capable and the sort of the other issue
with that so for both of those reasons
you kind of need this trust in the team
to actually use these effectively and
the other issue with that is that these
things could these problems come up even
more when you try to use sort of
functional programming techniques use
something like immutable J's
and you look at the types for immutable
J's it's littered with any types so
basically every time you're choosing to
use that style of immutability you're
deciding I won't use types and program
does sort of a sort of a similar thing
like a lot lots of RAM des works fine
with typescript but then there are also
a lot of parts that don't where
basically every time you choose to use
that one convenience function you lose
your types and that the issue there is
that in JavaScript basically types and
immutability work best when they're
pervasive but javascript isn't designed
around types for immutability you can't
make them pervasive except by convention
except by trusting sort of your team and
saying this is how we do things so what
if we look beyond javascript another
quote from Oscar Wilde the longer I live
the more keenly I feel that whatever was
good enough for our fathers is not good
enough for us in software as in politics
the grandparents are always wrong if I'm
translating that correctly and it's
interesting because a lot of these ideas
were actually written by our
grandparents like our grandparents came
up with these ideas many decades ago
but so what if we assume that we have
strong types and immutability and peer
functions what can we do with this and
how can we sort of take this further I
think the biggest thing for me with
those is just this idea of sort of
fearless refactoring you can just forget
about a bunch of things that you used to
worry about you stop worrying about
unexpected data you stop worrying about
data just kind of changing underneath
you and you stop worrying about the
stupid things that break the plumbing
between your functions and you can build
these reliable strongly-typed you eyes
you can say what if we make our dome
strongly-typed or if you want to do your
CSS and sort of a strongly-typed away
which makes it easier to maintain and
easier to develop or you can do
interesting things like generative
testing which is this example is
actually from haskell but it works the
same way in peer script basically where
you can say i have a type here and the
type here so what if instead of writing
a test that does just test one thing
like sort of one situation you generate
a bunch of tests with a bunch of data
based on those types and then you see
that certain properties hold so what an
interesting thing you can do with that
which I was playing with a few months
ago is if you're writing a distributed
algorithm and then you want to verify
that the trace of the algorithm
basically the state of the algorithm at
each step fulfills certain criteria like
in this case if we have a shared
resource that it only has one owner
during that trace and you can generate a
bunch of these traces based on the type
and the big thing just being that you
can stop worrying about the plumbing and
start thinking about the real problems
you have to deal with like the folks
over at awake security who have 20,000
lines of pure script presumably related
to intelligent network security or the
guys at slam data wrote their front-end
in pure script for doing visual
analytics for no SQL data or the people
at foam which have an interesting
project building this secured location
service on top of aetherium that they
wrote in pure script
or this talk which is about nine hundred
lines of code appear script written on
top of reveal J s just because it made
it easier to do thank you
[Applause]